hello reject so we're going to watch the
trailer today season one teaser trailer
of the 2017 reboot of Tales from the
Crypt and nice scheme' lemon under
banana and is doing this one so that's a
watch scary mob scary mock looks like
bill Mosely
meet George Carlin
[Music]
[Music]
not the right woman whoa really and let
the right way not a creeper is it oh
[Music]
whoa oh man I was pretty neat that was
pretty neat from what I've read about
this they're putting together these two
shows and Tales from the Crypt but they
want to do with it is make it a
half-hour ontology series with short
films in between I think like during the
breaks of the two new shows there's
going to be like a real-time ten episode
season long I forgot the names of the
ships there's going to be a ten episode
season long real time show then there's
another show that they're going to be
Erin says like a two-hour block that
they're going to have for this and this
would be a half-hour anthology show
Tales from the Crypt and then they're
supposed to do like short films in
between so I guess this is just a teaser
as that the one of the many episodes
will probably get from Tales from the
Crypt from looking at this it does have
a lot of the kind of you know definitely
exactly like the original Tales from the
Crypt
but you still do kind of have that dark
humor is vibe about it especially with
the way the lighting is like it's not
bright and it's not exactly cartooning
it does remind me this like spooky
boogeyman [ __ ]
kind of you know flicks from the 80s and
90s I did see this video that M night
Shyamalan released where he's talking
about how he wants to honor the dark
humor from the comics and that's part of
what made Tales from the Crypt so
special and even though this isn't
exactly like a funny clip you can feel
that humor kind of present behind the
filmmaking here it doesn't look like the
kind of style and effects and see I'm
like American Horror Story it has where
that sneaky flair to it so I'm excited
to see what they got in store for this I
know there's like there's been a lot of
production problems with this it keeps
going back and forth between oh it's not
going to be done they're putting it on
pause and I thought this was on positive
then they released this so I guess it's
still going you know it's gonna air soon
hopefully M night Shyamalan had a
tanking career comes back with a visit
really comes back on top of split I
really feel like he needs a third movie
and II feel like really does bring us a
great rendition of Tales from the Crypt
this could solidify him as like a horror
master this other thing I saw that he
was a horror master around like I don't
name know if we call my master just yet
but I feel like with the visit split if
this does well I feel like Shyamalan is
really set some people feel like
Shyamalan is already truly back would
split I feel like he needs one more
project to prove that he's really back I
was like rule of three thing in my mind
I feel like if Tales from the Crypt does
really well yeah Shyamalan is in pure
form again y'all excited for this you
decided for Shyamalan to adapt another
thing that has a former source material
we know how that went last time
subscribe to the reel rejects I'll be at
the greg alba on instagram and twitter
if you guys haven't seen split like i
gotta ruin it for you
bruce willis he he's dead the whole time